you have to be grateful i tell you why
because when you are grateful you become
less self-destructive here's how i use
gratitude in my own life second
something goes wrong like maybe i know
what if i don't get a job i want or what
if my wife won't give me what i want
possibly it's conjugal activity or
possibly some kind of dinner or possibly
it's approval you know there's a myriad
of things that i require from my life
partner wife partner gratitude means
that instead of focusing on the one
negative thing that i'm not getting in
that moment i focus instead on the many
things i already have two wonderful
daughters this beard a lovely house
freedom not poor anymore not on drugs no
more not signing on i've got a tattoo of
a snake on my finger people can argue if
they want that it looks like a worm
dragging a handbag they can say whatever
they want to me but i know that it's a
mahony original the principle of
gratitude is an important one we can
control our consciousness through
attention and intention